Nick starts off this hour in Michigan hi
Nick how are you hi mr. Ramsey it is an
honor and a privilege to speak to you
today yeah you too sir how can I help
try to keep my composure so please bear
with me
I've been legally blind for my whole
life
and I came to the United States and I
had a surgery and after that I could see
pretty well well now my vision starting
to go back and the next I would say 2
years 2 3 4 years
I'm I'm not going to have I'm not going
to be able to do much of anything as far
as work goes so um I want to preface
this by saying that you know when I was
15 I started with what I jokingly call
it kind of an IT company night I you
know I didn't take this lying down
but I kind of lived my life kind of like
I would never lose my vision and I just
don't want my my daughter I won't do
does they come a failure it does I just
I just need help figuring out what I
should do ok hmm let me ask you this um
when you look at your friends or family
and you observe their life and you think
well their success or their failure what
do you base that on
um um what is someone just what's up
what's someone that's the success looked
like um I would say someone that you
know tragic you're of there takes care
of their kids and you know does their
best type of thing yeah but Earl
Nightingale had a great quote and I've
always lived by that because I was
taught that as a very young age by my
parents who were in the real estate
business his quote is that success is
the progressive realisation of a worthy
goal or idea and so success is not
defined by Fame it's not defined by
power it's not defined by dollars it's
that you are making progress on a
predetermined path and so whether or not
someone watching from the outside says
your success is not relevant you know
now we've got you know world's the
world's definition of a success but what
you proposed to me was more important to
me than the world's definition of
success
and that was you didn't want your
daughter or your wife to feel like you
were a failure what you said right
that's correct and it's more so you know
when I look at when most people look at
job ads and the sort of thing I don't
want to say people are lazy but you know
what I have Apple fire and me too
to do because I have to do 10 times
better than just for me to be and end
and to be respected in spite of your of
your challenges yeah yeah so so I don't
want to I don't want to leave my family
with with with nothing and I understand
that so here's the here's my point okay
let's pretend this happens and let's
pretend this is our worst case scenario
how old are you I'm 30 years old how old
is your daughter she's so one year old
okay so let's pretend 18 years from
today you're 48 and she's standing on
the stage getting her diploma from high
school and someone asks her about her
dad and she smiles and she says he's the
hardest-working guy I've ever met
he's always had a fire in his belly he's
always out there making something happen
he's always put my mom and me first
he's had a lot of challenges but he
never quit if she said that I think she
just said my dad's a success don't you
yeah none of that had nothing you didn't
hear a single number in there
she didn't say he's a millionaire
multi-millionaire she didn't say makes
to five hundred thousand dollars a year
she didn't say he's a brain surgeon she
didn't say any of that
she was observing your effort and your
character and the quality of your
process that you go at this the attitude
you had that's what she's observing and
that's what will make her a great lady
by the way is when she watches her dad
do that
I see I mean on the more I believe
everything you just said on the more
practical side what can I do to I mean
because honestly that there isn't a job
I haven't looked at and all of them
require you to have some type of vision
as far as I can what well you said you
did IT yes sir is there not a
methodology for using ITV for the sight
challenged um you mean like like voice
recognition or Braille keypad or
whatever I don't know I'm asking yeah
yeah yes sir there is I just I'm just
mean more along along the lines of I I
need to have some type of a plan for you
know you need a clear track you need a
career path to eat that's different and
I want my daughter and my wife to view
me as a success okay yeah I guess I want
both yeah I want you to I want you both
to but they're kind of two different
questions so I don't mind getting a
tactical with you as well but I think
you just start going okay how can I turn
these lemons into lemonade and how can I
actually turn this into an advantage
rather than a disadvantage I've got a
good friend I'll send you a copy of his
book it's the copy of the book is called
the boy born dead now is your site where
you can still read or do I need to get a
audio version III would appreciate an
audio version okay if they've got the
audio version I'll get you one okay and
I don't think we've got to Kelly but
just go get it and send it to him I'll
find it and the guy's name is David ring
and
he's got cerebral palsy and when you
first start talking to David I hit him
on the air here the other day when you
first start talking to him it's hard to
understand him because he's got that
cerebral palsy Lisp you know what I'm
talking about
yes sir and you know what he makes his
living doing what he's a speaker that's
just silly it makes no sense at all
he speaks 275 times a year he has for
over two decades he's one of the most
sought-after speakers in evangelical
Christianity because he's got a great
story and he tells his story and he's
actually used his disability as he is he
calls it his challenges to become his
brand now I don't know that that but my
point is sometimes you can turn this
thing on its head and turn it off and
hit it in the right direction so I just
I guess I just wanted someone that I
think you're going to do okay because I
think what's going to dictate this is
not the technical tactical application
of where you're going to make a living
it's the fire in your belly and the kind
of man that asks the question that you
just asked is the kind of man that's
going to be okay and if you need help
you call me I'll walk with you I'll help
you over the years let's stay in touch
this is the Dave Ramsey show you guys
would be so rich so fast and be able to
do so much not only for yourselves and
for your family but for others
Oh